[Music]
in double-standards news submitted by
Pollos hermanos Poros boy else hermanos
boyo so you didn't see bring it back one
of the best TV shows in the world action
Pollos hermanos jermaine dupri got
backlash after dismissing current female
rappers wait is he killing it in the
background game though like he's always
been in the background but it's just
funny that his opinion matters so
[ __ ] much yeah I don't know he's a
producer he was really famous in the
late 90s and early 2000s he produced a
lot of artists back in a day like oh
yeah like east coast artists news a
frontman for a little bit and you went
back into the behind scene right yeah
dated Janet Jackson yeah Jackson that's
crazy what they married so Jermaine
Dupri he had a people now interview and
this is the clip that went viral silts
oh my god the thing that just happened
before I press play on this clip is they
were asking him if he has a favorite
female rapper and the he ends up going
like Oh big trouble I don't think
they're showing us who's the best rapper
I think they're trying to show them for
me um this is like strippers rapping and
I don't know cardi B frog rap goes I
don't I'm not kidding who is the best
rapper okay you got a story about you
dancing in the club you got a story
about you dance and then stuff you guys
throw out you dance in the club okay
alright what is the thing that you want
to see if you're not like just more I
mean I feel like at some point
somebody's gonna have to break out of
that mold and just show us of you know
talk about other things like rap just
rap about other things like cosmic okay
guys so I've seen a lot of people write
that nowadays female rappers or you talk
about the [ __ ]
[Music]
not obviously something about a
reservoir everyone Lizzy because she's
my best friend is because it like her
she's also here I am gonna fun because
let me tell you something when I did be
careful people will suck your man [ __ ]
in the beginning like what the [ __ ] is
this this is not what I expected I
expected this I expected I saw his light
if that's what people aren't trying to
hear then all right then I'm gonna start
rapping about my [ __ ] again
like Jerry asks off and don't be talking
about gay [ __ ] and don't be talking
about you know getting down in there no
one wants to hear it yeah I don't be
supported yup yeah don't be supporting
them and then be mad don't these
bloggers don't support them they don't
give them the recognition so don't blame
that [ __ ] on us when you're not the one
that's supporting them all right I like
that our [ __ ] are best fin yeah we do
that's a dope line cuz that's my best
friend okay I'm gonna talk about my best
friend I feel like the genre of what
works out is I I don't know I think
little Kim kind of started it all and
then it went from there well I think
what's popped up though is for him to
call women out for that when male
rappers I've been doing the same [ __ ]
like how many [ __ ] you [ __ ] how many
people you kill it's like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about you know rappers
rap about [ __ ] all the time yeah it's
like the same [ __ ] get money hate these
people it's like shut the [ __ ] up
Jermaine he don't belong speaking man
with timberlands name
that's from um say what they say and
said mmm so it was a wonderful call-out
it's actually dr. Dre saying that ah
yeah obviously Jermaine Dupri got a [ __ ]
ton of backlash
little brat did defend him but they're
also like best friends of course so he
was praising little brat how she broke
the mold and she did different things
and she's the one that paved the way for
the female rappers of today oh no much
saying that no ho so then uh
Queen Latifah [ __ ] paved the way for
a lot of people yeah so then about Joan
of Arc did Missy Elliot wasn't Queen
Latifah before miss you know she was in
the 80 I don't know she was yeah yeah we
it's all before sister was it sister sis
not ours and it was that three roommates
the black girl living single sister
sister the two twins yeah Canton man
yeah yeah after all that backlash
Jermaine Dupri posted this on his
Instagram though so deaths a female
cypher and the caption it says after all
the calls DMS angry tweets and other
messages saying quote I am a major
gatekeeper in the hip-hop world why
don't I invest in any female who is out
here hustling and making a name for
herself I decided to create the hashtag
So So Def female ciphered details coming
fast oh yeah dough but too late man
exactly so you know is it just black or
you know the six black rapper guy he
spells his name with the 600 yeah black
I guess he tweeted women in hip-hop
don't need representation / approval
from men parentheses your cypher sounds
more reactive than proactive yeah if you
don't have a favorite artist that hits
on the subjects you want to hear you
solve that with a quick search and some
support plus if they do want to talk
about sex they can't yep yeah and I
think Jermaine is I think he has his own
personal preferences which is okay but
there are a lot of dope female rappers
and emcees out there he's just not
listening to them also I hate when they
separate it like that oh this is the
female cypher you know oh you're good
for a female but if it's rap it's not
like an athlete competition like I get
splitting the sexes when it's like a
physical competition but it's rap you
could you could mix the sexes they can
still battle each other and HIPAA has
it's just changed over the years so much
to where he might miss the lyricism and
the old-school type of like emceeing
that existed but it's still to me it's
just a evolution of little camp all the
all the sexualized like female rapping
it's just that it's just went that way
so I kind of understand what he's saying
but I think he did a horrible [ __ ]
job at explaining himself when people
are always gonna follow the trends you
know yeah I mean that's just the way
it's going and in all the women like you
know Nick human [ __ ] Nicki Minaj and
and and uh cardi B and the women that do
speak about more of a provocative sexual
nature like there are a lot of women
that relate to that or also find
empowerment in female sexuality and they
doing it in a different way where maybe
they are owning the sex instead of like
becoming a subject of it so there's that
that maybe he doesn't even understand
but also it's like that in hip-hop all
around like like guys [ __ ] too you know
like it's not changing as much everyone
sounds the same like everyone sounds
like Drake a lot of people you know
mumble yeah it's all the same [ __ ] so I
get where he's coming from but I think
he did a really sorry job cuz as a
producer he could have used that
opportunity to champion a female and see
that yeah I'm in breakout he could have
also called out some dope female MCS
that he's like you know what in the game
right now I appreciate this person this
person this person because they're
breaking the mold yeah he could have
said that instead of taking the negative
route and going like yeah
none of the email rappers these days
yeah they're all sexualized and it's
like well you're [ __ ] it up and you
can't do that yeah and it also shows
that he's not up on his own game cuz
like he should be listening to different
artists from all like all underground
and you're stubborn like you said that
could have been the perfect opportunity
for him to shed light on this
underground female rapper or just rapper
that's like yo maybe right now I don't
have anyone mainstream but this person
right here is tight as [ __ ] and the
older generation just never likes it a
newer generation anyway like it's been
like that since the beginning of hip-hop
and music cuz k rs1 had a lot to [ __ ]
say about the 90s generate or the 90s
West Coast rap and in everything else
and then like a lot of West Coast
artists had a lot to say about when the
south and those guys came into the scene
is I just think it's just it's just
always gonna happen the older generation
is looking at the younger ones like oh
that's not music I liked when he did he
was like there is no RB if no one's
doing R&B
now yeah yeah there well he's kind of
right but there is but they're just not
popular right well I think they have
their own idea of what are like RMB and
Rath has evolved past these old guys
yeah
so like for me I understand them because
I also miss the music that I listened to
growing up but I also am aware that
music has evolved past me so I'm just
not understanding the new R&B or the new
rap that's coming out but obviously
they're still there so they're
outselling the old artists so there are
people out there that yeah I mean what's
happening is like if you want to be
technical with music I think everything
is becoming pop so regardless if it's
hip-hop or whatever these genres are
everything is going toward the direction
of mainstream music and pop so we don't
have these like niches anymore
but you have like country adopting
hip-hop you have R&B adopting like
trance or whatever and then it's all
mixing toward becoming pop john rowe so
when you made that reference it might be
that like he's saying you know it's not
there's no R&B anymore because
everything is pop now which i think
that's what's happening to music
everything is just mainstream pop not
really well I mean it's funny I feel
like the double standard is coming out a
little bit too cuz I remember when
people got on Taylor Swift's case about
always writing about X's I like she just
broke up with whatever and new album's
coming out and then like hating on her
for that and she was like you know male
singers write about their exes all the
time and no one like talking right
people just want to find hate yeah you
just want to hate for no reason I think
everyone gets criticism constantly but
why does it stand out more when it's
female is it because lately there's more
of a spotlight on females gaining so
much like blame for certain things or
maybe just females aren't respected in
any professional life the way men are
cuz you were just telling me there's
this very strong power lifter named
Stefan who is like hands-down the
strongest woman out there right now
and she's the one coaching her husband
who's pretty strong as well and anything
that comes out of her mouth people are
always questioning and hating on yeah
she clearly knows what she's like she
has a doctorate she has a DPT
any advice that she gives she gets
roasted on hated on and her husband says
the exact same should they love them
kind of like to take a news yeah yeah
it's girls in a male-dominated industry
in comedy all the time with stand-up and
that's why I hate like personally don't
like the female cyphers because when
it's like female stand-up night actually
why like why can't we just all do stands
rapping is a male-dominated world right
yeah they're just there's no respect and
you're gonna be just get a fine-tooth
comb more cuz people are looking for
reasons to hate or or say why you
females don't belong in that industry
yeah and like that when you're saying
how when women like listen to like the
sexualized song is whatever gonna get
Armin from it some males are not getting
that part they're just like oh there's
because it's not their world right
that's what I think yeah it's difficult
to understand that if it's not your
world
yeah cuz if they're rapping about
[ __ ] and hoes and [ __ ] are like oh
yeah right and a [ __ ] is like I'm a
[ __ ] I'm a ho and Matt moto see they're
like wait that was what wait we were
objectifying go against myself
hey you're using my own units against me
that's not fair
[Music]